everybody I know in Florida are so happy
to be there they love it yeah and we've
been watching this for a while since
we've been on the five like remember
that U-Haul costs yeah San Francisco to
Texas the one way was like so high and
there's more research showing that it's
getting worse I love that she's begging
right now that hopeless begging she
reminds me of a really stupid guy who
dumps his girlfriend because he thought
since he has his girlfriend he can have
any girl right he's like you know I'm in
a relationship and The Grass Is Always
Greener and now she's gone and he's a
sobbing mess she's him she's now looking
up all the X's you know for emotional
support please come back I was wrong but
the fact is there's no cost benefit
advantage to being in a city the blue
cities have now become cities of that
blow a lot and a lot has to do with you
know the crime and stuff and I feel like
DeSantis speech writers are watching my
show because he's comprehending he's
comprehending the Zeitgeist which is the
spirit or mood of a country Jesse thank
you at a particular time I'm going to
write that yeah and the Zeitgeist is
that you and you can feel it that we're
all done with the woke yeah you know
it's kind it's over and before it used
it basically blew through America and it
scared the crap out of people and nobody
and it's been and so we all just sat
there and we said oh my God you know
cancel culture it's here to stay but
then all you had people started to
realize no if you actually just share
the risk remember we said that if you
share the risk and you face the bully it
just collapses and now I think you know
you know he's he's at the tip of the
spirit right now with Florida it's good
to see meanwhile The Burbs talk about a
flip the burbs are now cooler than the
cities you still got the great
restaurants you got you know music you
got and you don't have Theater which is
great so anyway no crime no homelessness
and you're in in the suburbs you know
cities might be dead and Jesse one thing
that DeSantis has that other Republicans
in Washington don't have is this ability
to be separate from like what's going on
on the house side or so I thought you're
gonna say the great hair oh because he
had a nice set of hair on that I didn't
know it was that good but it looked
pretty good and you're right he's kept a
safe distance from all the drama in
Washington which is good for him do you
remember what it was like when we were
at the Patriot Awards in Florida yeah
how it felt different the hotel we don't
need to get into all that right
do not go it felt more fun it felt Freer
the freedom felt Freer and I can imagine
if we were there maybe not half the year
but one day more than half the year how
great that would be for our taxable
income and I don't know if everybody
knows this but I'm taking my taxable
income yeah and making a mass Exodus to
the state of New Jersey not a red state
but a red dur State than New York and
I'm not going to miss the city uh I'm
not going to miss the Ubers the traffic
the excessive tipping at every coffee
shop
I was in the West Village for a while
remember I got beer poured over me
people yelled things at me I was the
real victim those those Fox and Friends
guys get pretty mean but it's definitely
going to be nicer to be in the suburbs
where I'm appreciated more and respected
by people that like me Jessica do
Democrats not care about this kind of
Exodus from Blue states to Red because
they figure that the people who are
leaving are ones they don't want to have
there anyway like what local said in
July no there I mean it's obviously
contributing to some degree in the
Florida example the fact that now it's
ruby red right I mean Florida is now a
place that Democrats cannot contend on
the same level that they used to be able
to but you do have to question whether
people are they're making these changes
but are there politics changing right so
a lot of people who went to Texas they
went to Austin right which is a bright
blue City in there
and they're living the same lives but
better quality of life in terms of their
houses are bigger and their kids schools
were open and were open throughout covet
and will continue to be and that's
something that I really think was
driving this I understand the taxes is a
big deal
and the crime is a big deal but what it
really was for people at least in my
cohort with young children that they
wanted their kids in school and they
were going to go to a place where that
was going to happen for them so it's
obviously a trend it's troubling
especially High tax states like
California and New York we can't afford
to be losing all these rich people right
that's basically what Kathy hokels
saying like rich people please come home
because we need to tax you somebody just
come home please come home it's your
phone home but the cities are still
great just in defense of them and
granted no one pours beer on me in the
West Village but no I'm so nice she is
so nice nobody pour beer on her all
right